targaryen heir to the iron throne i've  never done a part i've shared with an  actor before even when you're not kind  of watching that work you are  building something together  is sort of odds with the gender she's  born into she grows up as the decentred  child she's female so  no one expects her to have any power but  what i love is again centering  well what is a patriarchal culture and  what it means as a female character to  try and uh work in opposition to that we  meet a renera who is bold and  self-assured  and is initially powerful in the way  that she's different she knows her  difference i think the thing that i  adore about it is that it's so rooted in  in the domestic and the familial it's a  it's a giant show and yet it sort of  stays on the ground i mean the things  that we deal with are  like commonalities in most people's  lives so talking about  love and death jealousy and aspiration  and it's reflected in like a beautifully  written script